la président madame la Première ministre
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
le 30 novembre dernier
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté à
l'unanimité la résolution visant à
sanctionner les herbes avec Jean à
exiger le retrait de ses forces du
territoire arménien
la France a le devoir d'exercer toute sa
solidarité à l'égard de l'Arménie elle
le doit pour des raisons historiques
contenu des épreuves terribles suivies
par ce peuple elle le doit pour des
raisons morales car ce qui est en cause
c'est le principe de nationalité elle le
doit aussi pour des raisons
géopolitiques vis-à-vis un peuple qui
est enclavé isolé perdu au milieu d'un
environnement hostile je voudrais dans
cet esprit vous poser deux questions 1
le gouvernement partage-t-il les
craintes qui sont celles des Arméniens
sont les risques d'une relance imminente
de la guerre par l'Azerbaïdjan les
gesticulations diplomatiques récentes de
ce pays en particulier le refus de
participer au sommet européen prévus à
Bruxelles et surtout le blocage pendant
plusieurs heures du couloir de la Chine
c'est à dire la remise en cause de
l'unité territoriale de l'Arménie ne
sont-ils pas de fort mauvais augure
deuxième question
le gouvernement français entend-il
contribuer aujourd'hui à la préservation
des droits et de l'identité culturelle
voire au maintien dans les lieux à la
survie physique des populations
arméniennes du haut-karaba quelles
efforts des poils pour mettre en place
les garanties internationales qui sont
nécessaires pour assurer cette survie
comment ne pas voir que c'est l'identité
d'un peuple et la survie d'une nation
déjà tragiquement éprouvée par
l'histoire qui se joue aujourd'hui
je vous remercie monsieur le président